>> WE ARE GOING TO BE GIVING A
VERY STRONG REPORT AS TO WHAT WE
THINK HAPPENED.
I THINK IT WILL BE VERY
CONCLUSIVE.
>> Martha: IS IT ANYTHING THAT
WAS ANYTHING NEFARIOUS OR JUST A
MISTAKE.
>> PERSONALLY, I THINK THEY MADE
A HORRIBLE MISTAKE AND THEY
DIDN’T WANT TO ADMIT IT.
WE WANTED TO GO IN.
THEY DIDN’T WANT US THERE EVEN
WORLD HEALTH WANTED TO GO IN.
THEY WERE ADMITTED BUT MUCH
LATER.
YOU KNOW, NOT IMMEDIATELY.
AND MY OPINION IS THEY MADE A
MISTAKE.
THEY TRIED TO COVER IT.
THEY TRIED TO PUT IT OUT.
JUST LIKE A FIRE.
REALLY LIKE TRYING TO PUT OUT A
FIRE.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN NEWT
GINGRICH, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND AUTHOR OF TRUMP VS. CHINA
AMERICA’S GREATEST THREAT.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: I HAVE HEARD SOME
OPINIONS ABOUT THIS.
THE PRESIDENT -- THE GOVERNMENT
IS TELLING US THEY WERE TRYING
TO STOCK UP ON THEIR MEDICAL
SUPPLIES THAT’S WHY THEY DIDN’T
WANT OUR COUNTRY TO KNOW.
THAT’S WHY THEY WAITED ALMOST A
WEEK TO TELL EVERYONE.
THEORY THEY ARE SUCH A POWERFUL
COUNTRY, THEY DIDN’T WANT TO BE
THE ONLY ONES AFFECTED BY THIS
AND THE ECONOMY WAS AFFECTED
ONLY IN CHINA.
SO THEY DIDN’T TELL THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>>
>> WELL, I THINK WE DON’T KNOW
SOME OF THEIR MOTIVATION BUT WE
KNOW WHAT THEY DID.
AND I THINK IF THE CHINESE
WANTED TO CLEAR THIS UP, THE
DICTATORSHIP COULD ALLOW
AMERICAN AND OTHER WESTERN
SCIENTISTS AND MEDICAL DOCTORS
TO VISIT WUHAN, TO VISIT THE
LABS TO INTERVIEW THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED.
I THINK SECRETARY POMPEO WAS
ALMOST CERTAINLY RIGHT WHEN HE
SAID THAT THE PREPONDERANCE OF
THE EVIDENCE NOW IS THAT IT CAME
OUT OF THE MILITARY LACKS.
IT DID NOT COME OUT OF THE
MARKETS.
AND, IF THAT’S TRUE.
THAT RAISES SOME VERY SERIOUS
QUESTIONS.
THERE HAS BEEN A LONG PERIOD OF
PEOPLE WARNING ABOUT THE CHINESE
LABS THAT THEY ARE VERY BADLY
RUN.
THEY ARE VERY UNSTABLE.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A REAL
PROPENSITY TO LEAK OUT OF THEM.
AND TOUGH RECOGNIZE, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT PROBABLY BY THE
TIME THIS IS OVER, MORE THAN
400,000 PEOPLE WORLDWIDE WILL
HAVE DIED BECAUSE OF THE CHINESE
DICTATORSHIP.
THIS IS DIRECTLY THE FAULT OF
THE DICTATORSHIP WHICH AS EARLY
AS NOVEMBER, FIRST CASES AND AS
EARLY AS THE MIDDLE OF DECEMBER
BEGAN TO REALIZE THAT THERE WAS
AN EPIDEMIC IN WUHAN AND LIED TO
THE ENTIRE PLANET UNTIL VERY
LATE JANUARY AND HAS NEVER
ALLOWED ANY OF THE WESTERN
SCIENTISTS OR DOCTORS TO COME IN
TO WUHAN AND FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
SO, I THINK THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IS ON THE CHINESE.
AND I THINK THAT FRANKLY THE
CONGRESS AUDITED TO BE HOLDING
HEARINGS ON THIS.
WE OUGHT TO BE ADOPTING
LEGISLATION TO ALLOW AMERICANS
TO SUE THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND WE
OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT
REPARATIONS FROM CHINA.
I THINK THE GERMANS HAVE
INDICATED THEY THINK THE CHINESE
OWE THEM $149 BILLION FOR THE
DAMAGE THEY DID TO THE GERMAN
ECONOMY.
THE AMOUNT HERE WOULD BE
INCALCULABLY BIGGER.
STEVE: OF COURSE.
NOT ONLY HAS THE UNITED STATES
BEEN HIT SO HARD, NEWT, YOU WERE
THERE --ARE THERE IN ROME, ITALY
THE GOOD NEWS AFTER 8 WEEKS THE
LOCKDOWN IS GOING TO BE LIFTED
TODAY.
4 MILLION ITALIANS WHO WORK IN
MANUFACTURING AND CONSTRUCTION
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO WORK.
SPEAKING OF GOING BACK TO WORK.
U.S. SENATE GOING BACK TO WORK
AT 3:00 THIS AFTERNOON.
U.S. HOUSE IS NOT.
NANCY PELOSI, THE SPEAKER, USED
TO BE YOUR JOB, SAYS NOT GOING
TO DO IT RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, I THINK, I SAW
SOMETHING CORRECTLY THIS
MORNING, SHE HAS INDICATED
PROBABLY GOING TO COME BACK NEXT
MONDAY.
I THINK THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR
EITHER THE HOUSE OR THE SENATE
NOT TO BE IN SESSION.
YOU CAN’T ASK THE REST OF
AMERICA TO TAKE RISK.
EVERY TRUCK DRIVER, EVERY
GROCERY STORE CLERK, YOU KNOW,
EVERY FIRST RESPONDER, MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS ARE TAKING RISK AND
IT’S REASONABLE TO ASK OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN A PRUDENT
WAY, FOLLOWING SOCIAL
DISTANCING, WASHING THEIR HANDS
AND WHEN APPROPRIATE WEARING A
MASK.
BUT IT’S STILL THEY OUGHT TO BE
AT WORK AND REALLY PAYING
ATTENTION BOTH TO THE CHINESE
ROLE BUT ALSO WHAT’S HAPPENING
AT HOME LET’S SWITCH GEARS AND
TALK ABOUT THE RESPONSE.
OBVIOUSLY JOE BIDEN DOESN’T
AGREE WITH ANY OF IT.
HE COMBINED WITH ELIZABETH
WARREN KIND OF INTERESTING
COMBINATION THERE TO WRITE AN
EDITORIAL IT.
SAID THIS:  THERE IS NO
OVERSIGHT -- HERE IS AN EXCERPT.
NO CORONAVIRUS THAT’S WHAT TRUMP
WANTS.
QUOTE FROM THE OP-ED TRUMP SEEMS
TO THINK IS HE DIRECT FOUNDING
TO THE CRISIS DEPENDING ON WHICH
POLITICIANS ARE NICE TO HIM.
WHICH STATES IS HE TRYING TO WIN
IN NOVEMBER AND WHICH BUSINESSES
HE WANTS TO ENRICH ALL WITHOUT
ANY ACCOUNTABILITY, WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT VIEW.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE AT ALL.
NO ONE HAS REALLY SAID THAT BUT
HE HAS POINTED OUT ILLINOIS WHO
SEEMS VERY HOSTILE AND HE IS NOT
REALLY PULLING OFF THE MOST
EFFICIENT PERFORMANCE.
BUT, DO YOU THINK THAT’S AN
ACCURATE PORTRAYAL AND WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF THAT COMBINATION OF
THOSE TWO WRITING TOGETHER?
>> WELL, LOOK.
I JUST WENT THROUGH ALL OF
YESTERDAY’S INTRODUCE.
THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR OF NEW
JERSEY WAS PRAISING TRUMP.
GOVERNOR CUOMO OF NEW YORK HAS
PRAISED TRUMP.
EVEN THE GOVERNOR OF ILLINOIS A
LOT OF RESOURCES.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA, A
DEMOCRAT, HAS PRAISED TRUMP.
SO, I THINK THAT BIDEN HAS GOT
US -- IT DOESN’T MATTER WHETHER
IT MAKES ANY SENSE OR NOT.
AND I THINK HE IS IN A DIFFICULT
SPOT RIGHT NOW.
SO, I THINK HE -- YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME HE WILL ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT THE FACT IS WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CORRECTLY CUT OFF
TRAVEL FROM CHINA, IT WAS BIDEN
WHO ATTACKED HIM AND SAID IT WAS
RACIST.
IT WAS XENOPHOBIC.
BIDEN HAS TO LOOK BACK AND SAY
WAS TRUMP RIGHT?
I THINK EVERYBODY AGREES HE WAS.
WAS TRUMP RIGHT OR SHOULD WE
HAVE FOLLOWED THE BIDEN POLICY
WHICH WOULD HAVE ALLOWED ANOTHER
COUPLE HUNDRED-DOLLAR CHINESE TO
FLY IN BRINGING WITH THEM THE